when you first entered the workforce as
a professional actor what sort of a
career did you envision for yourself as
far as balancing it or not balancing it
between theater versus television versus
film and then can you take us back to
the decision that came I think maybe
three four years ago where you were
offered an opportunity to go to Broadway
with a play that you'd already been a
part of and made a very it was a very
difficult decision for you but you
elected not to do that because of sort
of an idea of where you want to take
things so it was very selfish decision
as well because it affected a lot of
other people I did there 8 months before
we were supposed to go but apologies to
Nancy Carol and agents Cobra and Thea
Sharrock I just wanted to mix it up all
the time I really wanted I wanted to I'm
in my theater training Atlanta was who
was a classical theater classically
English theatre one year course and a
postgraduate course which I really
enjoyed and got a lot out of but you
know it would that was it that was the
main focus because I thought a little
bit old-fashioned in my kind of
understanding of it I thought that what
I do what the great actors that have
been ahead of me had done and inspired
me to do was the idea of starting out in
the classics then maybe a modern play or
two and a few roles and television and
then you know getting a film role but
keep going back to theater and that is
what I've done that is kind of what I've
tried to do the unhappy accident of that
play being such a huge success was it
came at a point where I thought Christ
I've actually got some momentum in a
medium where it's much more of a closed
door there's a very little long-term
memory it's much more immediate your
currencies something you really have to
kind of work on in film quite fast to a
to a degree I'm saying this in cogitate
everything I say tonight is contradicted
but I know that but it says I guess
that's what the personal conversation is
really it's just a point of view but um
every time I say everything I'm thinking
the opposite is also very true that's
the kind of yeah that's my head you're
getting into my head it's great being me
so yeah and I I really I was really
lucky to have just had a few breaks
obviously with Charlotte but also Tinker
Tailor also with Frankenstein and being
cast in
warhorse and that all came in the same
kind of point where we were supposed to
be coming here to do this Broadway
production of after the dance which
might still happen might be a film we
don't know it might it's something there
might be some life left in it it was a
wonderful experience in London
but I felt that I'd had that experience
there and selfishly I wanted to make
some capital out of this momentum that
was building and I I'm glad I did
because I got star tracker and -
obviously I was Osage County and yeah it
were it worked out well for me but um
and and and the Fourth Estate so I I
kind of I was very yeah I took a gamble
and it paid off well so that decision as
you say led to all these other roles
where that have only further raised your
profile since then and one of the
byproducts of that I thought I want to
ask you about is clearly you know you
are now a conservatively more famous
person than you were at the beginning of
this and I wonder how that impacts you
as an actor because correct me if I'm
wrong but it seems to me that part of
what makes many actors great actors is
the ability to kind of go out observe
other people behaving as they as they do
and channeling that and when you become
quite famous I think that it made me
make that loan yeah so I mean does that
make your life harder as an actor
there are ways of their ways of
remaining disguised in plain sight as
Sherlock would say but the you know to
be honest there are a lot of famous
actors who are still doing great work so
they're obviously managing to observe
something of of real life however
bizarre there's get but um yeah it was a
concern in a sense but I'm what I value
more than that is privacy and I there
are means and ways to extract yourself
enough to be able to observe human
nature and work through whatever medium
of research or understanding of
character or the human condition that it
is you need to be able to get that and
surprisingly you know some of us do take
public transport still I've got a
motorbike as well and I Drive a car
sometimes but I you know it's not
exclusive to the world of everybody else
but I know what you mean it's it's now
more about being conscious of this sort
of thing we're not I think a private
conversation I thought we were
but you know that's weird that is weird
and you know you're constantly at the
kind of mercy of people who are
basically with smartphones walking
publishers so you kind of you you under
being a performer understanding what a
camera is and what being observed is I'm
very highly attuned to that so you're
right to switch that focus back so that
I'm the one doing the watching is is is
a new craft for me but I'm managing it
and there are still quarters of the
world that don't know who the hell I am
so that's that's always good but um
there are also an incredibly supportive
amount of people that recognize me but
let me carry on my business and it's
fine it's just a sort of skill I guess
to balance and it's interesting I mean
I've got friends here tonight and you
know they've seen this sort of change
where but you know in it basically and
one of them said oh he said you know the
all-nighter that unless I'm actually in
my house with your you and your house
and I'm with you
I don't get you because there's always
always gonna be some of them wants to
interact have a conversation or you know
it's happened last night we're in a
restaurant and this screen just got
pushed aside there was a flash bugger
off of my face and this is it I was like
wow that's that's a first
you know always lock the toilet door I
mean you should anyway yeah and I don't
know yeah it's weird it is with it is it
is a it's a it's a learning process and
I'm in fact my infancy of it but you
know I think some of its helped but the
fact it's happened in my mid to late 30s
so you know there's a there's a sort of
perspective which kind of gives an
ability to breathe and try and extract
yourself a little bit from the madness
and say no and just learn that you know
you can politely decline something and
you're just step back a little bit but
also how to engage as well and I'm more
comfortable to my own skin that I would
have been you know this happened ten
years ago without a doubt so and in that
way it's a blessing yeah so I don't know
the exact chronological order of when
you did these things but in the past
year we have seen you apart from
Sherlock in fifth estate hobbit 12 years
of slave August Osage County goat season
well Thursday's sure like and star trek
into darkness
and it just it's just unbelievable in
one year you can't clearly it's hard to
even imagine how busy you must have been
and so I wonder you know do you do
anything specific between projects to
sort of cleanse the palate in a way or
are you able to jump from one thing into
something completely different
relatively seamlessly yeah I formed a
production company I did a short film
that was the hardly cleansing the palate
but I know I do I try to I've been
really fortunate and it's a very
high-class problem to have but it is
it's increasingly difficult it's
something I want to try and change in my
work pattern whereby you know the last
sort of - - I mean this is a bumper crop
of five months worth of film releases
coming out from about one and a half
years work but in those one and a half
and two years before that a lot of
projects have dovetails and that's kind
of that always makes me anxious because
not not for fear of repetition although
there is always that fear but I always
choose one of the criterias only way for
my choice of work is is to have
variation you know selfishly just to
keep myself amused and to stimulate
myself in a different way so even though
I don't know I had a bank holiday
weekend between the end of the third
series of Sherlock and parade's end and
before Sherlock I just I'd literally got
off stage we get this right yeah I got a
stage four on Frankenstein I think had
about a week before we started filming
Sherlock I was pretty damaged after
Franco sighing both Johnny and I were
pretty beat up so not ideal but they're
very different characters very very
different characters and it was really
weird this I'd literally was picked up
in a car on our last night from the
National Theatre our after party got in
a car driven down to Strathfield say we
were filming I was on set on a horse
charging with 80 other horses that sort
of 8:00 in the morning with Seville go
Spielberg going that was great you want
to do it again that's great and just
going yeah yeah I think I just sort of
slide he's forming off my saddle but I
mean such a different kind of Russian
and experience to finishing a place of
being on that kind of a set with the
live animals I mean you cannot compare
the experiences and it was like what
after the what what what play was that
you know so it was that's the most sort
of intense turnaround I think
and ideally yeah and I think it's
important you should have and I try now
to have a shedding period of a bit of
time so I just get rid of the last one
star having some fun then I just sort of
Center and go back to neutral and find
out who I am friends and family are very
handy for that as is travel and just
isolation from the madness of it all in
any shape or form and and then yeah
start wrapping it up for the next one
just slowly cooking the reading and
thinking about what the challenges are
going to be speaking to people they know
more about my character than I could
ever possibly dream of knowing and
relying on the brilliance of the
outside-in stuff with it whether it be
wardrobe or hair and makeup and and then
obviously the collaboration all the way
through that with a director in
conversation in person and in rehearsal
hopefully at this time that's the ideal
that very rarely happens but I mean you
know it would be good it happens every
night again but yeah and particularly I
think with with you played a number of
people who were real who are in many
cases still alive and you know going
back to Stephen Hawking right through
Julian Assange and others in between I
just wonder how from what I gather
you're a real real real researcher real
do a lot of preparation and but yet in
some cases you seem to have met with the
person in other cases you elected not to
or you couldn't or whatever I just how
do you approach it differently when it
is somebody who who is a real person
most recently Asajj well there are two
things I suppose that are immediate and
very obvious which is there's a moral
responsibility because that person in
particular his life is still very much
evolving his situations very precarious
and there's a responsibility to not do
him in an injustice which a lot of his
followers in him said that I did but I
was trying very hard not to my
correspondence with him was to try and
eat from him what I could bring to you
know work the part into something more
empathetic I wanted to meet him not to
study him and then turn him into a
two-dimensional [ __ ] I wanted to make
him somebody who's complex inhuman
inspirational and extraordinary and
unique and did who's done something
which is profoundly important for
democracy and I believe I believe he has
and hopefully some of that is reflected
in the film I think people who are
slightly more they know
it's partisan the right word I mean as
an impartial this what I'm trying to say
did like to say that it was that if
anything he was slightly more biased
towards towards his point of view I
don't think it was I think it was fairly
balanced but I understand what his I
understood I don't understand what his
his beef was with it it quite rightfully
you know it's based on two poisonous
accounts to his idea of what that story
was for his experience and to him it was
something that was yeah absolutely
antithetical to everything he tried to
achieve and you know he was dancing on
the on the grave of the box office flop
that it became but I'm still really
proud of it as a film and I'm really
proud of my work in it and I'd stand by
it if I was off at the part again
tomorrow I'd do it in a heartbeat I mean
to try just if I do justice to a man
like that I think he's the only
Australian I've met or I met but a
conversation with or heard opinions of
that doesn't think the accents good
every or that I'm not like him every
other Australian you know IIIi but I bet
seriously there's a real care of duty
and when it's slightly less I mean that
was very complex because there was a
morality that was very current and it
was so politicized every action of being
involved with it was a political
statement as much as you know he thought
I was sort of working under the auspices
of the DreamWorks / the State Department
I you know I'm a hard gun I really I can
tested that in quite a quite a fully
email to him but um you know I feel
strongly as an actor that you should
allow - you should be allowed to try and
dance with these very complex subject
matters and it's tricky because most of
the real people I played as pretty
extraordinary characters whether it's
van Gogh whether it's Stephen Hawking
whether it's Julian Alan Turing recently
and you know I can you know what we'll
all we do is is is is the most light
vague interpretation or impression of
these people and their true depths and
brilliance and you know the cinematic
art form in itself is something that
condenses years worth of experience
moments that stretch out into boring
infinity into a Eureka moment or a you
know a moment of high drama everything
about it is is riddled with complexity
because especially when it's a writ of
real life you think we'll goddammit I
know from my research and I know from
talking to this person or from my
reading that it didn't happen like this
and it raises a big question it makes
you go well why the hell are we doing
anything about real people but yet we
need some access I think some narrative
access to understanding these
extraordinary people in these
extraordinary times so I always look at
it and I this is I notice a massive get
out but I do always look at look at it
as a fictionalized truth and I think
most canny audiences know that they're
got to go to something which has as rich
and complex a subject matter as well
yeah the mathematics of cheering a
code-breaking or you know astrophysics
and everything that Stephens amazing at
and and Julian and computer hacking
programming / WikiLeaks and everything
that he did you you you expect people to
come to it with a certain degree of
cynicism but that well this is a film of
this and if I really want to find out
about it it's a conversation starter
it's not a fixed point to judge everyone
by so there's that there's that as that
engagement and then there is obviously
the thing that these people do still
exist and often not all of them but
obviously but not van Gogh but you know
there is a there is an audience that
already understands these people through
a medium whether it's biographies or
articles or or documentary so how do you
bring about something that is both new
and invigorating and different but at
the same time has an echo something that
has to be a reflection of these people
so that that balance between
interpretation impersonations kind of
vital and you having a really good hair
and makeup team that's always helpful a
good script is also helpful good
directors ultimately the most hopefully
you think you could ever have and I've
been very blessed on that front
[Music]
[Music]